Hold on, son!
NARRATOR: In the
bayou, it's always
easy to find the swamp man.
This son of a bitch
[bleep]
Oh god, really?
NARRATOR: Just follow
the trail of destruction
he leaves behind.
Now, even when the
swamp man is just
trying to do a little work--
Hey, what the hell you doing?
NARRATOR: Accidents can happen.
What the hell
you doing, Shelby?
This [inaudible]
[bleep]
You ain't seen my truck there?
Oh my God.
You got pay me the
son of bitch now.
NARRATOR: But Shelby always
tries to make amends.
Let me see if
I can get it off.
[laughing]
I got to pay for it anyways!
How's that?
Got it back on the
road for you, man.
Hold on, wait.
Go go go go.
NARRATOR: Now,
sometimes, the swamp man
makes a slight miscalculation.
- Hey!
You all right?
I'll get it.
You need to relax a little bit.
Don't let it get you.
We can fix it.
- Oh, yeah.
Oh yeah.
[inaudible]
NARRATOR: But he's
quick to find a solution
and make everything good as new.
Oh yeah!
Turtle soup tonight.
NARRATOR: Shelby's been known to
go where others fear to tread.
[inaudible]
whether he should be
going there or not.
That don't like
like the trail.
Oh, oh.
Can it go through here?
I'm pretty sure
you can make it.
Hold on.
Oh my God.
- All right!
- Whoa!
Oh-- [bleep]
[inaudible]
NARRATOR: But sometimes
when you go off roading--
Come here and turn
this son of bitch over.
You all right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm all right.
NARRATOR: You just gotta
dust yourself off and get
right back behind the wheel.
Oh, my leg hurts.
Jenny, you better
go ready go get some.
Here we go, Popeye!
Take it easy this time?
All right, we got it.
Does it still move?
Oh, come on, Shelby.
Stinks, I know.
You got to get it.
NARRATOR: Now, the swamp
man makes a mess quicker
than a pig in a porta potty.
But when it comes
time to clean up,
he knows just the place to go.
- This is like a bubble bath.
- Yeah.
- Hey!
- All in that hair.
Out of the way.
Chill, man.
[interposing voices]
We got to get to the blow dry.
Let me dry your hair.
You don't know how that
work that son of a bitch.
Give me that bath.
- Hey, yo!
I'm forgetting my quarters.
[music playing]